- Welcome to Global Resilient Apps,
Guide to Multi AZ and
Multi-Region Resiliency
with using ELB.
I'm Jon Zobrist, I lead
customer success for ELB,
and with me is Felipe da Silva,
Principal Solutions Architect on my team.
Thank you guys all so much
for coming out so early
and during a keynote,
we really appreciate it.
And for those of you who are
here from Felipe's chalk talk
the other day, good to see you.
So we're gonna go over
some guiding principles
and then we're gonna talk
about multi-AZ resiliency
and then multi-region resiliency,
and then we'll wrap up with some Q&A.
If we run out of time,
which we probably will,
we will be outside in the hall afterwards
when we have free time,
so if you guys have any other questions,
we're happy to chat about your
specifics or architecture.
Well, let's jump right in
with everyone's favorite quote
from AWS of all time,
"Everything fails all the time."
Our faithful leader and CTO Werner Vogels
has said this repeatedly and
I think we all know it's true.
Things fail and when failures happen,
we have to deal with them.
We can't just hope they never happen.
And to mitigate failures, what do we use?
So we think of how do we become
more resilient to failures?
And from our resiliency hub,
which you all should check out,
we've got this definition,
it's the ability of a workload
to recover from infrastructure
or service disruptions,
and that's sort of the main area
we're gonna be talking about today.
Under the hood, there's a
couple drivers for resilience,
so it's important to understand
that both of these are important
when you're planning or
building your architecture.
The technical drivers are gonna be things
like having less downtime,
being more available for your customers,
making sure things are lower latency.
On the business side, you're
gonna have concerns like,
you know, we've gotta
keep our revenue going,
we've gotta keep our customer trust high,
make sure that we look
good in the public image,
and our applications are up and available.
We're mostly gonna focus
on the technical one,
but what are we actually mitigating for?
Like what is the problem
we're trying to prevent?
Or why are we being resilient?
There's a lot of things that you think of,
or I think of, the first
place as long these,
and they're oftentimes the
highly unlikely scenarios,
so you've got earthquakes,
floods, tsunamis,
all of these things which do happen
and we need to be prepared for them,
but they're by far the least common.
And moving towards the more common,
you've got data in state
where you could have
corruption of your data,
or you could have an invalid stored data,
or you didn't fully replicate the data,
and you can have issues
where failures in that area
lead to application impairments.
Then there's the core infrastructure,
the things we often think
about where it's the, you know,
racks, servers, power, air conditioning,
all within the data center
where the servers are running.
And then by far the biggest one we see
is this configuration and deployment.
Humans touching things in production
is by far the number one cause of issues
and outages for both customers
and for AWS service teams
and that's what we're gonna
dive into a little bit more too.
We aren't gonna go as deep or really cover
disaster recovery, which is
sort of the twin of resilience.
Disaster recovery oftentimes
focuses on having a process,
a procedure with backups
in a secure location,
oftentimes multi-region.
If you're just getting
started on your journey,
the multi-region disaster recovery
may be a good first step
into going multi-region,
but the difference here is your recovery
is going to be a lot slower,
you're gonna have hours to days,
you're gonna be doing
things like restoring
from a database backup
or relaunching servers,
whereas high availability,
you may have a primary
site and a secondary site,
but they're both live and running
and you want things to be able
to keep running in both of them,
and if the primary fails,
you fail over the secondary,
have higher availability,
or you go something like active-active
and have multiple primary sites.
And then we're always trying
to in turn improve these.
We wanna make sure that we're reviewing
what happens operationally,
taking the lessons and
building them into our plans
so that we minimize the fact that,
or the chance that we have impact
from a similar failure in the future.
So when we talk about
resilience on the cloud,
so we love the shared
responsibility model.
Resilience, like everything,
is a shared responsibility
between AWS and you folks.
The primitives we give you,
so we have multiple regions
all around the world
and we've got things I'm sure
you've all heard of before.
Within the region, we've got
multiple availability zones.
These are gonna be completely independent
infrastructure pieces.
One or more buildings,
can be many buildings in bigger regions
and this would be geographically isolated
from other availability zones,
but still close enough to
keep the latency reasonable
in the single digit milliseconds.
But these are sort of the
primitives we give you
in terms of where you put things
and how you structure them.
And let's hand over to Felipe.
Welcome to re:Invent, Felipe.
- Thank you. Thank you,
Jon, appreciate that.
So let's talk about muti-resiliency then,
and we are going to be
focused on ELB here,
but essentially, the tips
that we're going to give
applies to any workload here.
And let's start first with
a very simple application.
As you can see in this application,
we're not using ELB here.
There are multiple EC2 instances
running across different
availability zones,
then you have your database,
your primary database,
and everything is working fine
until you have a some dependency issue.
The primary database fails
or something like that.
And what you have to do here?
You have to failover from
that primary database
to your secondary or something like that.
And your service
availability looks like this.
It drops until the failover
initiates and then you recover.
Now let's talk about a different problem,
which is also very common.
You have hosts in one availability zone
that are unable to
connect to the database,
but the other hosts are not.
In this case, you don't want
to failover from the database
because everything is working,
but you need to failover
from the front door.
So this action to failover is
a failover on the front door,
and until you do that,
these users are going to face
degradation of performance
or they cannot connect
or something like that
and the availability
looks sort of like this.
It's not down, but while you
haven't applied the mitigation,
you see availability
slightly down, put that way.
And this could be due to host failure,
connectivity flapping,
or something that between
the availability zones
that cause the connectivity to stop,
and how can we actually improve this
and improve our service availability,
ensure that this is smoother?
And so let's talk about how ELB can help.
And ELB improves your availability
and by scaling transparently,
distributing the traffic to targets.
So you have multiple targets,
you don't have to manage DNS,
it performs health check,
and it manage the traffic
routing using DNS as well,
and that's the key part
that we're going to be
focusing here today.
A lot of the talk is going
to be related to DNS,
and essentially, that's one
of the mitigation points
that we use in ELB is
failing over using DNS.
And this is a typical
architecture for the ELB.
You see on the top part
there is the DNS part,
and that is we're going
to talk a lot about.
Then you have the load balancer,
then you have the target
group with your EC2 instances
or whatever you have, and you
have your dependencies there.
So the ELB distributes traffic to healthy
and appropriate scaled nodes
based on your workload.
And you'll see here, put a
screenshot of DNS resolution
using the D command and the DNS responses
actually returns it
being in a random marker
to distribute the traffic
evenly across all zone IPs.
So each IP here belongs to one
different availability zone,
and TTL of the record
is always 60 seconds.
That ensures that each
time the client resolves,
they get the newest healthy
hosts that are available.
So first of all, I wanted to talk about
from ELB perspective, which
piece we publish in DNS,
and the answer for that is
all healthy zones are in DNS.
So when you configure load balancer,
you can pick how many availability zones
you want to have available,
and as long as the availability
zone is considered healthy,
that availability zone IP will be in DNS.
And then let's understand
what healthy zone definition
is that contains at
least one healthy target
and the node and the zone is healthy
from the Route53 health checks,
and we're going to see more in a bit
'cause I need to explain how
the Route53 health checks
actually works and we are
going to cover that in a bit,
but stick with that
definition because that would,
we are going to use that
in our presentation here.
Let's do a quick walkthrough
on the DNS resolution.
So the users are connected,
they're performing a DNS resolution,
they're acquiring DNS servers,
they receive a DNS response
with the IPs of the healthy IPs.
They connect and
everything is working fine.
And then if there is a
failure or something like,
users go, they perform another DNS lookup,
receive the response of
the current healthy host
and they connect and they're back online
and that's basically the way
that the mitigation actually works.
In this scenario I put like
the load balancer node failing,
but it could be two different reasons
and that's what we are going
to dive deep into today.
So let's go back to our previous example
that I talked that there
was a dependency failure,
but the dependency that
was actually failing
is from one of the availabilities zones
to connect to our
database, so in this case,
you don't want to failover
your primary database
or something like that,
you just want to make sure
that you don't route
traffic to those targets.
And how to detect and
route the traffic around?
That's the question.
And the answer for that is health checks.
And before I start talking
about health checks,
I need to explain how we design
health checks systems of ELB.
We think about the two-tier
health check system
and that means we do two
types of health checks.
One, Route53 is constantly
performing health checks
against the load balancer
nodes that are running,
and when I say nodes,
is the IPs that that we publish in DNS,
the subset of nodes that are
a part of the load balancer
and could be ALB or NLB here,
and even classic load balancer.
So that's the first tier
and that ensures that we only
publish healthy IPs in DNS.
That's the first part, then
we have the second tier,
which is each node is
performing health checks
against your targets.
And you probably have seen
that in your access logs
of your targets that you see
health checks being performed
by different IPs if you have
cross-zone load balancing node
or something like that and
that's essentially each node
will have its view of the
which targets are healthy.
And, yeah, that distributes essentially,
we only send traffic to
targets that are healthy
and clients will only
see availability zones
that are healthy in DNS, just to recap.
And from the health check,
what are the actions during
gray failures or hard failures.
First thing is you want
to reroute the traffic
from the affected targets
or availability zones,
and then you want to
initiate target replacements.
Let's just recap real quick
on these target health check options,
what actually mean about
target health check options,
the response that your backends
are providing to the load balancer.
And often we see shallow health checks
and deep health checks,
and shallow health check is essentially
the load balancer is sending a request.
Your load balancer always sends a request
to your load balancer,
HTTP request, HTTPS,
and is expecting a response.
You configure the response code,
you configure the interval and so on.
So the load balancer
is sending a requesting
and is expecting a response
and you can provide
either a shallow response
or you can provide a
response that actually
you perform a program at
something extra that connects
to the dependency, make sure
that everything is working,
and so the shallow one is
basically you connecting
to the web server, retrieving a response.
The web server connectivity
is working fine, that's it.
That doesn't perform any
extra dependency check.
The deep one will do that,
but one thing that I want you to think
is that this would have
a high resource usage
because if each health check approach
would have to check if
whether you can connect
with the dependency,
whether you can do some extra operation.
That may be expensive,
so we don't have only these two options.
We actually have a third option
that we talk a lot about when
discussing with customers.
We have a hybrid health check approach.
It essentially combines
the best of both worlds.
You perform a synchronous dependency check
across your dependencies,
and then you populate a file or a cache
and then that you provide
as a shallow health check
to the load balancer,
and then essentially
you have the same thing.
Each health check approach
that the load balance
is taking reflects on the dependency state
and that allows you to,
if you have a gray failure
or something that you're unable to connect
or perform some action,
they ALB or NLB would route the traffic
around to a dif to other
targets that are still healthy.
Now let's talk about the static stability
and one of the codes that we have
for static stability is
when impairments occur,
this can cause resources
to be unavailable.
And in this case, if you
lose a third of the fleet,
let's say one AZ out of three,
this could lead to overload.
And then what is the answer for that
is you have to be statically stable
and you have to have that
redundancy pre-deployed,
and essentially you want
to have the redundancy
available across multiple
availabilities zones.
And that's what we actually do with ELB.
We always over-provision the load balancer
by at least one availability
zones to tolerate that failure
and that enables us to do
actually do two things,
a seamless DNS fail-away,
and also it gives us buffer
capacity for a traffic spike.
That's another thing that happens
because we also have that extra capacity.
And for your targets,
how you should think about
it is exactly the same.
You should pre-provision the capacity
to tolerate one AZ failures
if you want to be resilient,
of course, and scale up out quickly,
scale down and slowly
so you keep that capacity
while you're scaling down
and conservatively so you can sustain
if there is a traffic spike
that occurs in the middle.
And essentially, in this example here,
we have everything healthy
and everything is green,
but then if one is availability
zone has all targets
that are failing all of a sudden,
the other two AZ should
still remain healthy.
And essentially, that is only
possible if you pre-provision.
Now let's talk about
cross-zone load balancing
and what I want to talk about
the cross-zone load
balancing example here,
everyone knows what
cross-zone load balancing is
when if you have cross-zone off,
the load balancer, each
IP of the load balancer
can only talk to targets in
the same availability zone,
and cross-zone, it talks
to all targets in all AZs.
But what I want to talk about here is,
let's imagine the traffic
distribution is the same,
whether cross-zone on or off,
and you have the traffic
distribution to your targets,
and one thing that you're noticing here,
it's on purpose I put one
of the availability zones
to contain less targets,
and you see that the targets
in these availability zone
receive a disproportionate
amount of traffic
because the load balancer
can only send traffic
to those targets and you have less targets
so they will perform more work,
while in the cross-zone on,
that will be distributed
and compensates for the
disproportionate amount of targets.
But I don't want you
folks to think that this,
either if cross-zone on,
although the traffic distribution is fine,
I don't want to think about that
because that will not enable
you to be statically stable,
so my recommendation is
keep a proportional number
of healthy targets per availability zones
and make sure that your backend capacity
can handle an AZ failover,
and that is essentially
going to enable you
for static stability.
Now I talk about DNS,
so let's dive deep into the
DNS failover mechanisms.
The first thing is let's
imagine hypothetically
that we have one availability zones
that all targets are failing
and the question that I want to ask
is what happens in this case?
And the answer is it depends,
and that's why I explain what
cross-zone is and how it works
because if you have cross-zone off
and all targets in that availability zone
are failing health checks, the
IP is also removed from DNS,
even though the load
balancer is not unhealthy
from its perspective, because
it cannot send traffic,
it doesn't have any healthy targets,
then essentially the IP is
going to be removed from DNS
and that distributes the traffic
to only the availability zones
that contain healthy targets.
And if cross-zone is on
and the load balancer in
that availability zone
can still send traffic to
other targets in other AZs,
the IP is not removed from DNS.
One thing that is very
important to think about
that this failover occurs
on the data plane level.
There is no control plane involved
and this happen for
application load balancers
and network load balancers.
Let's dive deep a little bit more here.
So let's talk about the
one important aspect
of the load balancer as well
is that we don't fail close,
we always fail open.
And you can see in this diagram
all targets are failing,
so all IPs should be removed from DNS,
but that would essentially
return a no record
and then clients will not connect.
We don't do that, so what we
do is that at the DNS level,
we fail open and then
all IPs are returned,
regardless of being unhealthy.
But one thing that happens as well
is we flag that on the Route53
and we evaluate target health also fails,
so if you have a failover
policy configured
that would failover to another
load balancer that is healthy
or another resource that is still healthy
from the Route53 perspective.
And on the target side, if
all targets are unhealthy,
then we send all traffic
to any of the targets,
as if they were healthy.
It's better to send
somewhere than just fail.
I want you to think as well
like that these mask other failures
and prevent additional failover decisions
if you are always in fail-open mode,
and essentially, you
can be in fail-open mode
and still operating just fine
'cause you have a bad
health check, for example,
but you lose the ability
to failover the traffic
when a real failure occurs here,
so I don't want you to
think that fail-open mode
is the right mode for you to operate.
It's just that we like to offer that
because it works even in
case that you are unhealthy
and application is still returning data.
And one thing that I wanted to mention
is that this is 100% configurable
using load balancer target
group health thresholds,
and we are going to see that in advance.
Sometimes we hear customers asking,
"How do we monitor if my load balancer
is in fail-open mode?
I just want to monitor, for example,
and I don't want to see,
like basically if there
is a failover occurring,
I want to see can I create an
alert or something like that."
And a way that you can
monitor if your load balancer
is failing open, you can
create a same thing record,
a failover policy record,
so in a monitor record, for example,
that you don't use for production,
and you configure failover policy
and if, as you can see here,
the primary is pointing
to the ELB and it has a
evaluate target health enabled,
and the secondary returns a no record,
so if you detect, we put in
this example a no record,
but you can actually point
to anything that you want,
and when you capture that is not pointed
to your main load balancer is pointing
to the static resource
that you appointed before,
that is configured for, sorry,
then you know that the load
balancer in fail-open mode.
So don't use that record,
the monitor record for client traffic
because otherwise your
clients will fail to connect.
So let's dive deep in the
target health thresholds.
Remember that I mentioned that fail open
and failover in the previous slides
can only occur if all targets are failing,
and that is the default.
All targets must fail health
check in order to trigger that.
And again, just recap is the DNS failover
and the target fail open as well.
And these thresholds are configurable
and what we want to talk
about in this section here
is that you should configure
earlier intervention points
'cause if 100% of this is failing,
maybe it's too late so you can configure
to fail away before that.
And in this example, so
you have unified threshold
and detail thresholds where
you can separate the DNS
failover and the target failover.
The DNS failover has to occur first,
but in this example I just put
a unified one and I said 30%.
So if a target group contain less than 30%
of the targets healthy, it
would trigger a failover.
And you can see here not
all the targets are failing.
I still have two healthy targets
but they could be, that
could lead to an overload
or a bad customer experience,
so it's better for you
to fail away from that
availability zone if that occurs.
If you have multiple target groups
associated with the load balancer,
that's a very common configuration.
And the reason why I'm bringing that up
is we see sometimes
customer in fail-open mode
or failover scenarios,
but they have healthy targets
in the same availability zone
in the different target group.
And in this example I
put two target groups,
target one and two,
and the target group one
is a test target group,
for example, and a two is
serving the production traffic.
One thing that this feature allows you
actually to do is you
can go to that setting
and disable that for
one of the target groups
that's not serving the main
portion of your traffic,
and that essentially, as
you can see in this example,
the AZ is not returning DNS,
but if you disable that
for that target group,
it will still resolving,
still returning the DNS,
and if the load balancer
receives traffic on that AZ
and that points to that target group,
that target group is in
fail-open mode, essentially.
But yeah, at least the IP is not removed,
capacity is not removed from that AZ.
Let's talk about another
mechanism to failover traffic
is using Route53 Application
Recovery Controller.
So let's assume here that
you have this scenario
where you have canaries and
you're probing the load balancer
and detect the degradation or something
where your targets are not
considered unhealthy yet
due to some other reason,
you can actually go and
request a zonal shift,
and by request a zonal shift
application recovery controller
will remove that IP from the DNS as well,
and that's a mechanism
that you have control over.
And you also have a zonal auto shift.
If this is for us, if we detect an issue,
we can also perform the zonal shift
for you on your behalf.
You can use that as well for testing
if you can actually
tolerate that AZ failure
that I mentioned and ensure
that you are statically stable
so you perform exercises and so on.
In this example it shows
for cross-zone off,
but it can also be used in cross-zone on.
And please check on the QR code.
There are a lot of
information in the article
that this QR code is going to return.
Now let's talk about observability,
and I wanted to make a disclaimer
on the observability side.
Observability is a huge topic
and I'm not going to dive
deep on observability.
We won't have time to cover everything.
But, let's imagine here this scenario
where you have your users,
you have your load balancers,
you have your targets, and
you have your dependencies,
or a stack of multiple load balancers,
and the question that I want to ask here
is like where are you measuring
when things are wrong,
or things are doing well?
And the answer here is you
should measure everything.
So you measure from the
load balancer metrics,
but you also should emit
metrics from your targets,
collect metrics from
dependencies, and understand,
in case there is a failure or something,
you want to understand
what is the component
that is actually failing,
because you may see the front
door failing with something,
but the problem, actually,
it's on a database
that is down under on the stack, right,
so you want to make
sure that you know that,
so an indication of error
can mean something external
to the load balancer itself.
And the question when we
are troubleshooting things
is like for the failure is
occurring at a single zone
or it's occurring at multiple
zones at the same time.
And the reason why we ask this
question is if it's happening
from multiple zones and each load balancer
is seeing the same thing,
you can pinpoint that the issue
is not at the load balancer
because we provisional zonal resources,
and if we are seeing the same
event across all your targets,
for example, you may indicate
you have a dependency issue
but if the issue and you have
cross-zone off, for example,
is happening with a
single availability zone,
you can then verify like if
there are any specific targets
that are returning errors
in that availability zone
and so on and that's only possible
if you have those metrics available,
or you have to process
access logs and so on.
One thing that we do at
AWS is, in our services,
we do have, we monitor,
we don't only monitor
for negative metrics,
or in other words like errors,
we also monitor on the positive metrics,
meaning that your request
within the boundaries
that we expect, what is the 2xx rate,
canary are successfully probing the nodes
and the load balancers.
What is our health host count?
So if you see a sudden drop
in the health host count
and not an increase in
the unhealthy host count,
it's still a problem, right,
even though the unhealthy
host count did an alarm.
So these are things that
I want you to think about
when you're creating alarms.
You should also think about
your positive metrics here.
And one cool feature that
we have with CloudWatch
is the composite alarm,
so you can combine multiple
alarms into a single alarm
and that will enhance your visibility
when you're alerting your own call
'cause now you can see
which alarm is firing.
Maybe it's firing the 5xx
alarm on the load balancer,
but it's also firing
something elevated latency
on the target because
the dependency's failing
or something like that
and that will give you better visibility.
But again, as I mentioned
earlier, there are other talks
that talk a lot about observability,
I just wanted to give my thoughts
about how you should think
about observability here.
And client best practices,
and I want to start here on the client.
One important aspect of
resiliency is the client.
You can have a very good architecture,
well-architected, everything works fine,
but you have a client
that stick with a connect,
with a specific IP because they're caching
or something like that
and they don't recover when things fail,
or they don't detect,
or they detect that there
is a connection failure
and they keep retry on the
same same IP all the time,
that's bad, so one thing
that I want to mention here
is like are your clients ready?
Because it's not only DNS.
When you're setting up clients,
most web browsers will do
what we are explaining here
in this slide, but when you're creating
your client for your APIs,
your clients are ready
for connection management.
Do they have a maximum
connection persistent time?
Do you have connection pooling enabled
that can accelerate things
because you can pre-open
connections, essentially.
Clients are honoring DNS TTL,
and when errors are occurring,
do you retry on responsive
IPs and skip failed ones?
Do you implement exponential
back-off with Jitter?
And if you do that, then
you have loads of benefits,
you have a balanced
connection distribution,
you have graceful failure handling,
faster recovery times,
and reduced latency.
And this are just a basic, you know,
you're going to see
that only connection pulley example here.
You have connections, you're
connected to multiple nodes,
the client is aware that one node
is not producing the expected response,
it just ignores that node temporarily,
and then when that node recovers,
it reconnects to it and that's it.
And yeah, and that's it from my end.
Actually, going to hand over to Jon.
- Awesome, thanks Felipe, appreciate it.
So now that Felipe has gone
into multi-AZ resilience,
let's talk a little bit about
multi-region resiliency.
The first thing to talk about is
why would you wanna do this?
So why go be multi-region?
And the biggest thing, in my opinion,
that you get from going multi-region
is you get another level
of blast radius isolation.
So we talk a lot about blast radius
and how we minimize
impact during a failure.
The blast radius isolation
that you get will help you
with other things like
configuration issues or deployments.
It will help with region-wide catastrophes
if you're in a different region
where there isn't a catastrophe happening,
and it may help you with
legal or compliance reasons.
We are seeing more customer,
or more countries put
data sovereignty laws
where certain kinds of
data needs to be stored
within certain geopolitical boundaries,
and these are countries
that have them so far,
but it's a new trend and
we expect it to continue,
definitely an important
thing to think about.
So before you go multi-region,
the biggest thing, the
hardest thing about this,
you have to realize, I'm
sure many of you know this,
it's a very hard problem we're solving.
We're taking complex distributed systems,
building other systems on top of those,
merging them together and
then we wanna take that
and start moving it to other regions
in a way that synchronizes
with the original.
So the two biggest points
that I think we to do
when we're thinking a lot
about going multi-region
are one, align everybody.
Now this doesn't necessarily mean
you have to have your
customers aligned beforehand,
but during an event,
you need to be giving them the information
that you're all aligned on,
like what's the failure mode,
how we're recovering from it,
what are our expected recovery times
or expected behaviors during an outage,
and really keep that alignment going
throughout the lifecycle
of the entire project.
The other big thing is
simple, right, simplicity.
I mean, we've all heard keep it simple.
Simplicity scales, like
we see systems at AWS.
All of the big systems
have simple core principles
that they're built on and that's
the reason they can scale.
But keeping it simple
also gives you the ability
to reason about what's
going on during a failure.
So your new on-call at 3:00 AM gets paged.
If the system is simple
and he's learned those
and can take care of it,
like understands how it should behave,
they'll be much further ahead
and able to find out what's going on,
initiate any required actions.
So before you go multi-region,
there's a few things you should do
and you really should have
this multi AZ nailed down.
We do have customers who go
multi-region in single AZs
and when I see those architectures,
other than you get the
blast radius isolation,
you're really doing the same thing
as multi AZ in terms of failure.
You should have highly automation
for your architectures,
your infrastructure should be
defined in code if you can.
You want these things to
be fast, reproducible,
but the more important thing
with having it in code is it's consistent.
There's nothing worse
than setting up a region
and manually setting up another region
and you forgot to set some options
and now you've got a
difference that you don't know
until you actually are failed-over.
Your data authority and
replication strategy
should be well-defined,
and this is another thing to align on.
The people who are writing
the database queries
or using the database,
the backend engineers,
the front end engineers,
everyone needs to know
this is how we will know that
these values are correct,
this is our replication strategy,
this is how it will behave when we fail.
So one of the big failures
that can happen is core infrastructure,
and to mitigate these
failures we are responsible
for the resilience of the cloud.
And to do that, we actually
define our services
in three different groups.
And you'll notice up here
there's zonal, regional and global,
and global services
actually are control plane
in one region, data plane in all regions.
It's kind of multi-region,
but we don't have one up here
that's actually multi-region.
Like we don't build services multi-region.
As a service team, when we
deploy ELB to a new region,
it's essentially a completely
isolated incarnation
of the entire service.
So under the hood, when we're
building these services,
and when you're building them,
we can have a zonal service,
and the big difference here when you say,
"Should I be zonal or
should I be regional?"
Is am I building a core service
that other services are
gonna build on top of?
And if the answer is yes,
then you probably need to be
building a zone-only isolated service.
Hyperplane, which is what
NLB and Gateway Load Balancer
are used under the hood is
a completely zonal service.
Hyperplane in a zone has no idea
that other zones even exist,
and the way we do
cross-zone is we register
all of the targets to that
target group in every zone.
But these zone services,
when we build them,
will have a regional control plane
that has a common endpoint,
then they'll have zonal control planes
and data planes are always zonal as well.
Regional services is more
commonly what we actually build.
Most of our services are regional.
We have more of a big logic incarnation
of the service is in one, or sorry,
the whole region is one
logical incarnation,
and sometimes these will have
a control plane in the zone,
but they may not and they'll
have a regional control plane.
It's the endpoint you talk to.
It'll propagate to the zonal data planes.
Now under the hood, everything
is always going to be
physically in one zone or another,
so the data planes are still isolated,
even if they're aware of the
other zones and/or using them.
And then finally, we
have a very small number
of global services.
These are generally the edge
services like CloudFront,
but they're also services
like IAM and Route53.
And it's important to realize these mean
they're running in one
region, their control plane,
and if that region is impacted,
their control plane may not be available
in any of the other regions,
and this is why Felipe was mentioning
you wanna to keep your
mitigations in data plane
as much as you can.
Nobody likes to have an issue
that they need to run
something to react from
and then the API is actually down.
We build our control
planes to be resilient
and highly available,
but nowhere near the same
level of effort is spent
as compared to data planes.
So the other category of errors
that we can run into is
really data and state,
and when you're planning for this,
you need to consider and
keep in mind the CAP theorem.
So I'm sure everyone has seen
this in some form or another.
We'll just do a quick refresher.
Partition tolerance is the ability
to survive a network segmentation
where one component of your application
cannot work with or talk
to the other components.
In network apps, everything's networking.
You're at ELB talk, so you guys
are dealing with networking,
you have to choose this, right?
You can't not have partition tolerance.
If a user's on their desktop at home
and your application is
there working locally
and the data is consistent and available,
it's probably not the same, right?
They need to be able to
connect to something.
So we have to choose partition tolerance
and that means that we have to tug of war
between consistency or availability.
Now what are these, actually?
Consistency is the ability,
or not the ability,
but the requirement to always
return the correct answer.
So the correct answer could
mean the latest version
of a file, it could mean the
current balance of a ledger,
or it could mean something else
that requires additional state syncing
before returning and
saying, "Yes, we have this."
It does not mean that it will
always return a response.
Availability means it will
always return a response,
even if it's wrong, and wrong
here could be out of date,
it could be again like the ledger,
you could have a time from earlier
when you have the latest
value that you're now showing.
Most people pick availability
and then want consistency anyways,
and this is something
that when you're planning,
you need to be honest and say like,
"We need to be clear that we can't have
all of these things all of the time."
Now there's strategies you
could do to mitigate problems,
and we'll talk through some of those.
We just wanted to kind of
cover CAP theorem again.
Now, I mentioned earlier the
disaster recovery planning.
This is an important part of resiliency,
or an important part of availability,
but it's not really what
we're focusing right now.
If you're not having any
multi-region for your applications
or data and you wanna start,
this is a good place to say,
"Let's just ship our data
somewhere, our backups,
into S3 in another region,
and then it's less effort,
it'll be less cost overall,
and the downside is the
recovery could be hours to days
instead of hopefully seconds
in a more highly available
resilient system.
So data replication is
something that is a challenge
and it will vary a lot based on how,
or what your data is and what
your user's expectations are.
You can have multiple options
in terms of maybe you need
to write your changes to one region,
and maybe you need to
replicate to another region
before returning that write as a success.
You may have that kind of
consistency requirement.
You may just write to the region
and then have it lazy replicate
or use another system to replicate,
but this will help
determine whether you need
to have active-active in
multiple regions active
at the same time,
or active passive where
you have write regions
and read regions.
We have a handful of services
that actually give you global features.
DynamoDB, DocumentDB, and
Aurora global database
are all good options.
These will let you determine or configure
how your data will
replicate between regions,
as well as monitor it and
have metrics and views
and insights into what's
actually happening.
So when we are talking about a failure
and it's a regional size failure,
we need to failover somehow.
You've heard Felipe mention
that we're doing DNS a lot.
We actually use DNS for everything.
I think everyone knows, you
know, it's always DNS, but
when you're actually shifting traffic,
we're gonna be actually
changing DNS records
or updating them or
letting the health checks
dynamically change them.
And when you fail between regions
or you're sending traffic between region,
you're gonna be using the AWS backbone.
The backbone has multiple
layers of encryption.
It's DDoS resilient, a lot
of the hardware we designed
and built ourself, a lot of
the fiber we laid ourselves,
and it is highly scalable and
has a lot of good features
and you'll be shipping traffic
between regions using this backbone.
So when you're getting
your traffic into the ELB,
you have a few different options,
and Route 53 being the first one.
So you always have Route 53 with ELB.
It's because we're a Route53 customer.
We pay them for help checks.
They help check every single IP we have
globally all the time
and that carries over
to your DNS records when
you have an ELB DNS record.
You can also use CloudFront,
which will give you
things like edge caching,
WAF at the edge, Lambda at the edge,
other features that can help
get you into your load balancer
or global accelerator.
Global accelerator's real
advantages are it has static IPs.
You get two IPs.
They are in completely
different infrastructure
under the hood so there's no overlap.
It's another good level
of blast radius isolation.
They're any cast so you can
configure multiple regions
as targets and let AGA
or global accelerator
figure out how to route the traffic,
as well as the static IPs
that you don't have to
worry about changing.
So when you're actually having a failure
and you need to shift traffic over,
you want this again in the data plane,
and you can do this with Route53 records
if you choose the failover type record.
And in this example,
we've got a primary region
and a backup region,
and our primary region,
as long as it's healthy,
we will have traffic routing 100% to it.
But if the primary
region becomes unhealthy,
Route53 will detect that, flip
the DNS record to unhealthy,
and that will cause the
traffic to start failing over
to the failover region.
If you have an active-active workload,
you can use a weighted record,
which will actually let you
put in different numbers
for weights for each region,
and you could send, in this
case, 50% to the first region,
and 50% to the second region.
It does the same thing when things fail,
so if the first region goes unhealthy,
it's still gonna fail traffic over,
so it's 100% to the other region,
even though they're both primaries.
Now, I put 45% of impact
here because this setting
is what Felipe was talking
about on your target group
where you can change the threshold.
So you could say 50% of the
hosts need to be healthy
and this failover would
trigger exactly like this.
The default again is 100%
need to be unhealthy,
and we don't think that's what
most folks should configure,
but we hate changing defaults,
so definitely go spend some time
and look at changing that setting.
The simple version is use the unified one
and decide on what level of failure
you're willing to tolerate in
your application and set that.
But what happens if when
you shift this traffic over,
your new region gets overloaded?
We all know that when errors happen,
clients sometimes go
into connection storms,
reconnecting rapidly, sending
more and more connections,
increasing load and
making the outage worse.
If you're having an
outage and you failed over
a bunch of traffic from
one region to another,
or even if you're just
getting too much traffic
that you might be entering a
state of congestive collapse
where the problem creates
more of the same problem,
in this case, our backup
region is still healthy
but it's not 100% healthy and
we know it's because of load,
so we need to shift some traffic away.
You can use DNS load shedding.
So if you use a weighted record,
you still get those health checks
if you check evaluate target health,
and in this case we've got ELB one record,
it's showing ELB one,
but you would replace
that with the same thing.
The ELB two record is now
a new load-shedding record.
It's essentially going
to have its own weights
and it's going to say somewhere,
in this case a null route
to zero zero is weight zero,
and the main site weight 100.
And then if that main site
crosses its unhealthy threshold,
or if you wanna go change it so that it is
going to happen sooner, you're
gonna manually configure it
and say shift traffic to this.
In this example, we're
gonna send 20% of traffic
to a null route.
Clients get this, they
won't be able to connect
to your site, but your site
can then have a reduced load
and preserve the experience
for some of your customers.
It's not always the best option,
but in a lot of cases this is
what we can get you out of,
"Okay, we're having a problem,
we're in congestive collapse,
we need back pressure or load shedding."
And after your region goes healthy again,
you can update the record
and change it back,
so you're at 0%, and in this case,
we're still shifted over
to the back of a region
because their primary
region is still unhealthy.
These are all Route53 records
that you can configure
and there's more of them including latency
or geo records to say that
people from this geography
will go to this place.
These records are very
useful when you're creating
your global infrastructure
'cause you're doing multi-region,
your clients are gonna be closer
to some regions than others.
You'll want to configure your records
to ensure they're sending
traffic to the right region.
So let's go to the big thing
that we've talked about.
Most failures are caused by humans
changing things in production,
so we need to try to be
as careful as we can.
What does that mean?
What are the things we can actually do
to mitigate these configuration
changes and deployments?
The biggest thing is testing.
Now I'm sure everybody has
good testing, hopefully,
but this includes integration tests,
it includes the unit tests that
run when you check things in
and it includes automatically
running this test
at each stage of your deployment
or of your environment.
The other big thing is change management.
So we do a lot of automation
and I'm sure you guys do a lot
of infrastructure automation.
Those kinds of things are
allowed to continue on their own
'cause they have their own
systems for detecting failures
and mitigating things,
but when a human's
gonna change production,
we require to go through a
strict change management process.
You're gonna document everything
that you're going to do
and then you're going
to run it step by step.
And that increases visibility
and that increases the ability to say,
"When we're manually changing things,
we're not doing it without
asking a bunch of people
to review what we're going
to do and getting more people
so we're not in the heat of the moment
trying to change production."
What does that actually look
like when you're deploying?
So you've got code pipeline
is basically the thing we use.
You've got a pipeline of deployments
where you're gonna start
with some pre-production environments,
so someone's gonna write
the code and check it in.
It's going to get built by a system
and pushed to the first stage.
At each stage as it deploys,
you wanna have multiple
things that are checking
and allowing you to
forward that deployment
to the next stage or do
the deployment itself.
That includes all your testing,
so we run integration
tests in every environment,
in every region before any deployment
separately from the previous runs
and that'll detect things
like somebody change the value
in that region or
there's a different thing
that was built differently when the region
was originally built.
You wanna make sure that
you have a rollback alarm
that's going to, if that triggers,
you'll automatically roll things back.
You wanna make sure that's
green before you deploy.
You wanna make sure your
dependencies are all green
and you wanna make sure that
the time of the deployment
is okay within a schedule.
So a lot of folks schedule that
so they have deployments
in the middle of the night
or on the weekend,
but we don't really have a weekend
or a middle of the
night when our customers
aren't using our services,
so what we actually do is
we say we want you to deploy
in the region during the daylight hours.
We want the people who get
paged when the human change
breaks something to be
awake, alert at their desks,
maybe already ready to go and
able to start investigating
and not paid somebody at
3:00 AM to wake them up
and then they have to wake
up and figure out what to do
and we wanna make sure that
they're prepared for that.
So at each of these phases,
we're gonna run those tests
and then propagate to the next phase
after the deployment completes.
Alpha and Gamma, we generally think of
as like an Alpha is usually
just the teams changes
with production from every
other service that you use.
And then Gamma is usually
the services integration
where you've got all the changes
that your whole service is making.
Sometimes there's more
pre-production stages
once you get to your onebox stage
and onebox is just the name,
it doesn't always mean one box.
If you have a fleet of tens of thousands,
onebox may be dozens to hundreds
of actual application instances
that get updated as part of this.
It needs to be statistically
significant enough
that you can detect the
vast majority of problems
with the majority of your users
so look at how much traffic
your application sends
and pick a number here to
say, "That's our onebox."
A good answer is one if you wanna know.
And then when you go to the
production, we start zonally,
so we'll do one AZ and
we'll go to the next zone,
and then as we grow this
out, it just scales.
We can start touching multiple zones
or multiple regions in the same day,
but this is another place
where having alignment is a big deal,
like having a rule that
says you will not deploy
to two AZs in the same
region in the same day
means that you can look at this,
or it's even more crazy version, this,
which is not the smallest
pipeline I've seen at AWS,
but you get a simple understanding of,
okay, I know that none of those columns,
even though the labels
will actually say wrong
because I didn't edit every one of them,
but the labels will actually,
or so not the labels,
you know that each of
those deployment stages
won't be the same region twice in a day,
and if you see that, you wouldn't,
hopefully nobody would
put it into the pipeline,
but if you see it, you know
immediately that's a problem
with my configuration
and plan deployments.
But this scales and we do
deployments where we fan out
after we get more and more
confidence that we're detecting
or we would be detecting any issues
that are occurring from our deployments.
So another concept
that's very useful is
graceful degradation.
When you've got a failure
and you're mitigating it
or you're reacting to it,
you want your application
components to continue
to perform a subset of the core functions,
even if the dependencies become available.
A good example of this is
the dogs of Amazon page.
I'm sure if you guys have
heard there's this website,
Amazon.com, you can go
buy things on there,
and if you run into an error,
the graceful degradation
that the application sometimes
does is returns you a picture
of somebody's dog who brings it to work.
And first of all, you
get a cute dog usually,
and say, you know this is,
"Aren't they adorable?"
You also get instructions.
What do you do next?
Go back and try again.
You also get clarification
that this is on our side,
we had a problem, we got a 5xx.
Instead of just giving you a generic error
where you don't know what to do,
we've given you some
instructions what to do.
There are many other kinds
of graceful degradations you can use,
but the key concept is you wanna have part
of your functionality
or some level of information
to help the users
or whoever's interacting
with what's failing
to have a way out of it
without having to panic
or open a support case or complain.
Maybe they just retry.
Every time I've seen a dog of Amazon,
a retry has fixed it, but if it doesn't,
you'll still keep getting the same error,
and that error is a big part
of what's gracefully degrading, right?
The website didn't just return nothing,
it returns something,
even if it's not what you
were actually looking for,
but you have a step or you have an action
that you can do something.
Another example of this
is you actually scale in the
services you are running.
So there are customers
who have multi-region,
but the backup region is not
running the full application
and it's not expected to.
They're expecting that
when they fail over,
they're going to have a
subset of functions available.
So if you're a bank and that's the ledger
and you wanna say, "We always
wanna have the right version
or the right balancer for it,"
you're gonna make that right.
Go to the first region and
then to the second region
before saying, "Yes, we accept the right."
That way, if you fail
over to the second region,
you can have strong consistency
knowing we have the value
because we wouldn't have accepted it
if it wasn't already replicated.
But other features may not be there
in the second region, right?
Maybe I can't go make a
payment or maybe I can't go
and you know, file a something else,
like there's a bunch of
things you can not have
in your backup region.
As you build into this more and more,
now of course, you can
replicate everything,
run it in the other region
and have everything fail over
smoothly and have all of the features.
It's just this saves you some
money, as well as complexity.
If you know that during a failure,
this is how the system's going to behave
and everyone's aligned and agrees
that's the right thing to do,
it's gonna help you out a
lot and save some money.
But when you're thinking about this,
you're gonna be prioritizing,
"What do our users really care about?
What's the critical service?"
And make sure that they're informed.
So an example for our
availability in our CAP theorem,
if you have a ledger and
you have the latest value,
you could show the time where
you have that value from
and you could have that
cached on the client.
You could have that in the target
that gets it from the database,
but doesn't have it in
the failover database,
and giving that information to your users
can help them understand,
okay, I know that that
transaction isn't there yet
and the time shows me, oh, we
don't have the latest version.
And you probably also wanna say something
about we're experiencing a failure
or we're running in a degraded state,
but it's something that
gracefully you can help your users
have a better experience
or continue to maintain
function during a failure.
One thing that a lot of customers do,
but honestly the majority don't,
and I think it's undervalued,
is toggles and circuit breakers.
So toggles in your features would be,
we're deploying a new feature,
we deploy the things that make it work,
and then we watch to make sure
it's going to work the way we want,
but we can turn it on and
off without having to go
and do a full deployment.
Toggles can help you disable a feature
that maybe it's dependency
is having an issue.
Again, prioritize business functions,
resource-intensive features under load.
Maybe you don't wanna do that extra widget
that costs a whole bunch of CPU
when you're running in your other region.
Those are the kinds of
things you wanna think about
and remove from part of your failover.
Queuing also works well
serving cache content.
So if you are in a standard application
and your client has code that you own,
you can go change this and add things.
You wanna make sure you're following
all the TCB best practice
Felipe talked about,
but you could also have
local versions of say,
an error page, something
like the dogs of Amazon page,
or the latest version of the values
that you're going to request just cached
and then display them,
so you can gracefully degrade
right there on the client if you own it.
At the target group,
the health check
configuration we talked about,
you can use that to fail-away sooner
and make sure that your target,
your experience is
preserved for your users,
whether that's failing open
and sending traffic at the
target group, or failing away.
Load shedding is a useful thing
that gets you out of congestive collab,
something that definitely
is a very useful thing
to have happen or to be ready for in case
you get a surge in traffic.
And then rerouting traffic
to alternate regions
is another way you can gracefully degrade
and have your lower experience
or your reduced experience application
or your full application.
So let's go back over our
checklist, multi-AZ resiliency.
So use multiple availability
zones pre-provision
so you can have static stability.
Maintain headroom, at least
one AZ worth of capacity.
Use DNS everywhere at your client.
Make sure you're honoring DNS TTLs.
Make sure when your
clients are having errors,
they're reconnecting to an IP
that didn't have the error.
And think deeply about your health checks.
Configure them so that you'll fail-away
when you don't wanna send,
when the resource that's
in the health check
would have you do it, sorry.
The resource in the health check
that you're actually health checking
should it be in there or not,
you determine that by saying,
"If it's failed and I cannot respond,
would I want that response
to go to the customer?"
And if the answer is, "No, I wouldn't,"
then that should be in the health check.
And as that gets more expensive,
you're gonna want to use
strategies like the health check,
separate asynchronous leave from it
getting served directly
to the health checker.
On the multi-region side,
again, the biggest things,
keep it simple and align everyone
are the two main things
that really want people to think about.
When you're doing these things
and you're making these decisions,
you should not be doing it isolated.
You should be doing it as a group
so that everyone understands
this is the expectation during a failure.
That's it. Thank you
all so much for coming.
Really appreciate the early morning rally
and don't forget to fill
out the survey in the app.